this is the last video I film as Tana
mojo and probably the first video I
upload has Tana Paul but are you really
tan ja it's a marriage that's what
happened the answer is well no because
Tana just confirmed she and Jake Paul
are not legally married I wanted to not
do it legally but any wedding I have if
I had three more [ __ ] weddings I
really wouldn't want to do it on paper
because I think that legally binding
yourself to someone takes away the love
like it's just like it's unnecessary
Tana had just posted that blog filmed on
the morning of her wedding day and she
admits there's no legal paper and the
marriage is not legally binding is
anyone surprised yet still she says
their love is real to all of the people
that think of is not real we're just
putting on this show as - tosya bans it
is real that's all I know to tell those
people we are just crazy and that's what
you can talk about really and that's not
all I'm getting accused every second of
only marrying Jake for the reality show
which obviously is a very valid claim if
you saw Santa mojo and Jake Paul getting
married then it happened to be perfectly
timed with a reality show that she was
also filming I would accuse that of her
too but she stands by their choice we
would be dumb not to film it that's just
another form of like content of it to
look back on and like why end the show
on a random no when you can literally
end it like marrying someone that you
actually ended up falling in love with
and it was kind of like let everyone
else talk about it and sit back and look
like idiots and give the power away to
everyone else or beads henna mojo and
Jake Paul document it from our side and
play into the joke and take the power
back and I think it was the best
decision we ever made
oh yeah and there's this we're crazy for
getting married we could be married
forever or for ten days forever or ten
days which is funny cuz on Tuesday night
david dobrik told me he gives it three
more days and said the whole thing is
well just watch is it a forever thing
of course not oh no I'd be surprised if
it last another three days why do you
say that no I think they're just too
young and too crazy to stay with each
other I think they're both lunatics in a
good way and I think they won't be able
to handle each other in a real
relationship you know people have been
questioning I actually think they I
actually think they get along yeah but I
mean I'm sure they're gonna ask you oh
it's a betrayal No yeah of course et was
with Jake aunt Anna at their July 28th
wedding in Vegas you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
we've been calling each other got
something matters dad but now it's just
real and they had a lot to say
everything was unconventional you know
you're not supposed to see the brochures
differ yeah it was almost like imagine
if we had a normal wedding it would be
as fun it wouldn't be alright guys what
do we think is this even news are they
in it for the long haul will they break
up in 3 days 10 days or stay together
forever let me know and for all the
latest on this story keep it locked to
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
you